hey Luca Nate here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're
restoring a battle-axe
[Music]
well welcome to another episode of
outdoor boys and today we have an
awesome Axe restoration video for you
check this out have you ever seen
anything like that before
that is one cool axe isn't that Nate now
this is a bearded axe from Bulgaria and
I was told it was a battle axe now
whether that's true or not I have no way
of knowing but this thing is awesome and
other than being really rusty and
missing a handle it's in good shape
this is the coolest axe I've ever seen
and I am very excited to restore this so
let's get cracking shall we do it Nate
all right the first thing we need to do
is get the rust off this axe head and as
much as I love a shiny mirror polished
axe head I don't think that's gonna be
the best look for this project I think
leaving the the pitted weathered texture
on the metal will just make it look
really cool so I just want to get rid of
the rust but not otherwise alter the
metal so that rules out using abrasives
and instead I'm gonna try this product
called a vapor rust I was recommended to
me by I some some viewers I've tried
vinegar a coca-cola electrolysis and a
lot of other things but this is my first
time using this so hopefully it won't
completely dissolve my axe and ruin it
let's give it a go all right so we'll
put this in a five-gallon bucket and
we'll let that sit for a couple hours
alright it's been about five hours let's
check this out and see how we're doing
yeah that rust is just falling off
that's actually pretty impressive that
is a load better than coca-cola or
vinegar yeah that's like shiny steel
back here this is really impressive guys
this is just really knocked the rust off
there's just a few spots that are still
rusty I'm just gonna put it this side
down so I'll get submerged in that vapor
rust a little bit better and give it a
overnight and we'll see what happens
well let it sit overnight for about 12
hours in the solution and man the rust
just falls off look at that cuz wiping
it off with my finger there's actually
not that much pity this metal is really
smooth there's just a little bit of
roughness in a few places you can see
the seam right there where it's been for
welded they just drew this out right
here and folded it over its Forge welded
it right there and that's how they form
the eye so mostly down into bare metal
there's a few spots of rust still
lingering but man that worked really
well in just 12 hours so definitely a
lot better than what we call our vinegar
I am curious though when I can get off
some of these spots without messing up
the finish yeah well we got the rust off
and it looks pretty darn good we still
kept all the character and an age so
let's go ahead if the handle go on and
I've got a piece of African mahogany
here
[Music]
well guys I'm not very far along with
this handle and I've already fatally
screwed it up when I drew that sharpie
line on it to cut it out
I drew the sharpie line wrong and now it
is too thin on the head so the wood is
now too small for the eye of the axe so
I need to start over again anything are
you helping daddy yep
you pretending to fish ha ha ha ha right
buddy
[Music]
did you net me
well that went a lot better than this
time so hopefully I won't screw this one
up
well it's gonna be a little tricky
because this eye is not symmetrical
exactly you can see here that it's a
little low on this side of the eye but
we'll just carve it out the best we can
and hopefully this will fit snugly
well things were going pretty good on
this handle until it started raining on
me now I'm starting to get a bit wet so
I'm gonna put this up for right now and
as soon as we get a little bit drier
weather we'll start working on this
again will the rain stop if I only have
a few hours before I need to put the
kids down so we're gonna get cracking on
that
[Laughter]
well organized I got the ax fitted on
there
it's very snug very happy with how it's
done so far but it's raining and the Sun
is setting so we're gonna call it for
today I'm gonna pick this thing up in a
little bit well guys I put this project
down about two months ago and we have
been very busy did about a two and a
half thousand mile road trip where we
shot fishing videos and all sorts of
stuff all across the south and it just
got back from doing that got some great
videos here if you haven't seen those
already and I'm about to take off for
another big trip so I want to finish
this axe up before we go and you can see
here that just sitting around the
humidity in the air has caused quite a
bit of rusting so we got to go and
finish up this handle get it all done
take the rust off it which won't won't
be hard and then we've got to treat this
so that it will not rust up again let's
get started
[Music]
that looks pretty good all right let's
sand it down oh well that looks pretty
darn nice nice and smooth sturdy but I
think I'm gonna put some ornamentation
on this day all right you can see what
I'm doing is I'm using this chisel to go
ahead and put in these scale patterns
now I'm gonna go down and do this well
I'm not quite sure how much I'm gonna do
this got scales in there now I'm just
going to touch them up a little bit all
right got the fish scale pattern carved
in with the exacto knife now we're to go
and I want to add a little bit of
shadowing on it so check this out
nice and toasty I charge it too much and
I had to take away too much material to
to get at it so it kind of ruined the
effect a little bit still looks really
cool but you can't really tell it was
supposed to be fish scales anymore
I might go ahead and char the rest of it
to it I do like the way that looks all
right we got this little piece of
African mahogany here we need to turn
into a wedge so
there we go so I gotta get this a little
bit of rust off the axe here so I'm
going to go ahead and stick it in this
bag and put some of this vapor rust on
it
[Music]
[Music]
well this is where I'm supposed to be
putting my wedge but as you can see it's
closed up really tight just the
exactness of the fit has made it a
little bit too tight perhaps we're going
to try to get the wedge in and see what
happens
[Music]
[Music]
all right yo that axe head is on there
really tight
well there you go guys there's the
finished product you see the dragon
scales or fish scales on the side didn't
quite turn out the way I wanted but they
still look pretty cool very very beefy
sturdy handle that thing's not breaking
anytime soon it is thick it's just not
what it was designed for but man it's
crazy
this thing is awesome it looks so cool
and I've never seen anything like it
this axe is so unique but I really
questioned whether or not it's a battle
axe it seems really unwieldy for actual
combat but it looks cool whatever it is
and I'm not a hundred percent sure this
is from Bulgaria that's just where I
bought it from you know my guess it's
Eastern European of some sort but who
knows so if you if you know if you're
actually have seen one of these before
please share some information in the
comments I'd love to know more about it
the handle turned out ok not my favorite
handle by far the sanding took away too
much of the detail and it looks like a
cool texture pattern now but the great
thing about doing this yourself is you
know when I find some more time in the
future I can just pop this handle off
grab another piece of wood and give it
another try no big thing anyway thanks
for watching guys we hope you enjoyed
this video if you'd like to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe and check out our playlist
below I have an entire tool restoration
ax restoration playlist tons of great
videos of cool axes thanks for watching
guys thanks for watching we hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more great videos from the outdoor
voice youtube channel don't
get to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video